[MUSIC]
To sum up,
we've had an amazing ride here at Tesla.
And I'm so excited to lead
this company into the future.
With that,
I'll take any questions from the audience.
Yes.
>> Mr.
Musk, I am a very tiny shareholder
with only [INAUDIBLE] two shares.
But as all the other investors in this
room, I'm mainly interested in one thing.
You guys have not made a single penny yet.
When is this company
gonna become profitable?
>> Uhh.
>> Stop.
>> [LAUGH]
>> You all know what this feels like,
don't you?
And this is not where you want to be.
Today we will provide you with one
of your last lessons at the GSB,
a lesson on how to answer
tough business questions.
There are three types of
The first are those questions for
which you do not have an answer.
The second are those questions for
which you cannot provide an answer.
And the third are those questions for
which you are guilty as charged.
We will provide you with an example
of each one of these questions and
then offer some suggestions on how to
best address each of those questions.
But first, I would like to offer
credit to Jerry Weissman's book,
In the Line of Fire, from which we
synthesized many of these suggestions.
So what does it look like when you
don't know the answer to a question?
When is your Hawaii office opening?
I'm looking for a job.
>> Are you kidding me?
I'm the CEO of Tesla, for crying out loud.
I have better things to worry about.
Maybe August or December.
>> Stop.
>> [LAUGH]
>> There is a much
better way to address a question for
which you do not have an answer.
First, begin by rephrasing or restating
the question as you best understood it.
This will do two things.
It'll ensure that the audience member
feels heard, but it will also confirm for
you the question for which you
must ultimately provide an answer.
Second, no audience member expects
you to be a walking encyclopedia.
So if you don't know the answer, admit it.
You really have nothing to gain and
have everything to lose by lying.
If you lie,
you provide inaccurate information and
you risk damaging your reputation.
Finally, best practice is to actually
commit to following up, and do follow up.
You can even demonstrate
this intent by asking for
that audience member's business card or
contact information.
So let's try that again.
When do you open your Hawaii office?
I'm looking for a job.
>> So you want to know when you might
be able to apply for a job in Hawaii?
To be honest, I don't know exactly when
our Hawaii office will be opening.
However, I do know that we are rapidly
expanding all across the globe and
are looking for
talented individuals in many locations.
I do actually have my head of HR,
Leslie, here with me.
She'd be happy to meet with
you after this presentation.
She'd know when the Hawaii
office will be opening and
she'd be happy to answer any other
questions that you might have.
>> Now, what do you do if you receive
a question to which you cannot answer,
maybe because of confidentiality reasons?
Let's try this.
Mr. Musk, can you comment on your
negotiations with local state
authorities in the jurisdictions where
Tesla cannot currently open any stores?
Have you made any political
contributions in those states maybe?
>> Of course.
We'd be silly not to.
We have a good friend, an old fraternity
brother of the CFO, Jerry Arlen.
He's in Texas, and conveniently he sits
on the Texas Transportation Board.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Needless to say,
we think we have pretty strong negotiating
leverage with the auto dealers there.
We're currently in negotiations to get
full access to sell in the state of Texas,
and it should be done
in a couple of weeks.
>> Wow, I'm sure Jerry Arlen will love
to see this back on television tonight.
>> [LAUGH]
>> First,
if your company policy states that you
cannot share any information, just say so.
Everyone knows that certain
information cannot be shared, and
no one will be surprised by that.
However, try to do so in a positive way,
rather than saying our company
does not share this kind of information,
try to say our company policy only
allows to share information that has been
previously released in press releases.
Second, if you can't share certain
information, give a reason for
why you can't share that information.
You can attribute this to privacy or
security or data sensitivity, for example.
Third, if you have any extra
relevant information to share, do so
with your audience.
And last but not least,
never ever answer this question by saying
if I tell you I'll have to kill you.
So let's try that again.
Mr. Musk, can you comment on your
negotiations with local state
authorities in jurisdictions where
Tesla cannot open any store currently?
Did you make any political
contributions in those states maybe?
>> So we want customers to be able
to buy a Tesla wherever they live.
And as you allude to,
unfortunately that's not today's reality.
However, we are in negotiations with
several state authorities across
the United States, and we're working hard
to bring Tesla customers those cars.
However, to keep open and
honest negotiations,
it's our policy not to comment
on ongoing discussions.
But I can assure you that we're working
tirelessly to allow every customer to be
able to buy a Tesla where they live.
>> That was way better.
You're doing well, but
you're not of the hook yet.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I still have one more question for
you, and word of advice for you.
What should you do if
the questioner has a valid point?
What if we asked something that
points out one of your weaknesses?
So let's try this.
Mr. Musk, how do you expect anyone
to buy a car from you if they
are expected to spend 75
minutes at a charging station?
>> Did you get this information
from the University of Phoenix?
>> [LAUGH]
>> Who let this bozo in here?
No, our customers have shown
no reticence to buy cars
if they take a long time to charge.
We have no problems with this at all.
>> How would you feel if
you were the questioner?
How would you feel if a valued
concern is dismissed in this way?
I will explain to you a better way of
answering, a different way of answering.
First, paraphrase the questioner and
reframe the question in a way
that you show that you listened.
And you change the tone of
the question to make it more positive,
to make it most promising.
Then agree with the questioner.
He has a valid point.
Show him that you're on his side.
You're not an opponent.
And then say loud and clear but, and
make a U-turn to change
the tone of the answer
in a positive way, so
you can present evidence
to defend your own position while still
acknowledging the existence of this issue.
And finally, you have to
conclude with a strong statement.
So again, Mr. Musk,
I will give you a second chance.
How do you expect people to buy a car
if they are expected to spend 75
minutes at a charging station?
>> What I'm hearing from you is that you
have a concern that people might not wanna
purchase a Tesla if it takes
a long time to recharge.
I think that's a valid concern, and
it's something that I spend
a lot of time thinking about.
Currently it takes about 40 minutes for
us to give the car an 80% car.
And the 75 minutes you mentioned is for
a full charge.
But we've been working really hard and
have taken several important steps
to try to mitigate this issue.
Firstly, we just introduced battery swaps,
where people can come into a station and
switch in a new battery in 90 seconds.
That's faster than
filling up a tank of gas.
And secondly, we're constantly working
to improve our battery technology.
And as we can charge the car faster, we're
gonna get people out on the road faster,
and more and more people will
wanna buy our amazing vehicles.
>> That was the answer I
wanted to hear the first time.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Congratulations.
So, let's recap.
What did we learn today?
We learned how to answer three questions.
When you don't know the answer,
say so and offer follow up.
When you can't answer, just don't, but
always provide a reasonable
explanation for not answering.
And when the questioner has a valid point,
admit guilt.
It's fine.
It's good to connect with them.
But you have to spend enough
time to defend your position and
to explain why the concern
has been addressed.
We have seen him, how he evolved
throughout the presentation.
He has successfully answered
three questions, and
he's ready to take
the fourth one from you.
>> [LAUGH]
[MUSIC]